and he made a lot of claims with its rx
5700 series of GPUs like saying that the
new blower cooler is quote quiet where
Andy launched with tremendous power in
the CPU category especially the r5 3600
that we reviewed earlier today and we
recommend the company has had a much
more difficult time pulling together a
competitive GPU today we're benchmarking
the RX 5700 XT for thermals noise
normalized thermals acoustics power
consumption and gaming versus relevance
and video competition like the freshly
released Super Series before that this
video is brought to you by Thermaltake c
360 DD c hard tubing water cooling kit
if you're ready to dip your toes into
the water and build your first open-loop
cooling system the Thermaltake c 360 DD
c hard tubing kit comes with all the
components you need the kit includes a
three sixty millimeter radiator 3 128 a
RGB fans a copper w-4 a RGB water block
for the CPU a pump and res DDC combo and
all the fittings needed to build a full
CPU open-loop learn more at the link in
the description below we have a lot of
thoughts on na'vi that we need to get
through most of them will be in the
conclusion we're gonna get into the
benchmarks pretty quickly today but the
primer here if you missed the
architecture discussion we have a
separate video with david cantor talking
about the architectural changes in na'vi
our DNA is actually a genuinely new
backbone versus GCN so this isn't some
reason it has meaningful updates to it
so Navi is a new GPU to look at and
separately we do need to address some
decisions that Andy made with Navi that
will probably confuse some people the
most important of them is boost clock so
what everybody on earth understands us
boost clock especially people a dandy
because they've used it this way before
is that boost is basically it's it's
your expected clock in a reasonable
workload like gaming and then you have
base clock which is the expected floor
and that's sort of it that's what you
get for numbers there's a higher clock
that would be the peak clock but what
AMD has done is rebranded their clocks
because if you don't like the numbers
you invent new ones and the boost clock
is now a basically a peak opportunistic
clock is I believe the phrasing that AMD
is
so this is something that could be hit
for milliseconds at a time for example
so when you see the calculations on the
spec sheets that have for example the
amount of teraflops one can expect be
careful to distinguish between the one
at the peak o'clock which is not
realistic and the one at a reasonable
clock like the gaming clock so anyway
that's all that means game clock in
Andy's phrasing means basically the same
thing as Nvidia's boost clock peak clock
you should ignore and base clock you
should treat the same way you treat
Nvidia's base clock those two are mostly
identical so that's the marketing side
explained there are some other changes
as well like to overclocking the 5709 XC
can't overclock past a certain frequency
it is artificially locked and that is
done for product segmentation purposes
so that AMD can sell more of the
high-end cards and you don't just go out
and buy the low-end card and then
overclock it which is odd because the
CPU division works completely the
inverse to that you can buy whatever CPU
you want and overclock it and it can be
pretty damn good at the end of the day
so those are the primary differences
there are others too there were a lot of
driver issues
AMD push the second driver version to
press prior to launch we did end up
using that and the other one and this is
now becoming a trend with AMD launches
so we'll talk about that more than
conclusion let's get into the testing
we're going to start with thermals and
frequency plots will go through games
get through some power and noise figures
and then talk about the card on the
whole just to establish what sort of
frequency to expect with na'vi we'll
start with a frequency over time plot in
a fixed 3dmark workload and then move on
to game testing the RX 5700 xt doesn't
have the same frequency fall-off curve
as nvidia we're touring boost behavior
is extremely thermal dependent but it
does still have some thermal
dependencies the RX 5700 xt averages in
the range of 17 77 megahertz to 1890
megahertz with a lot of small
fluctuations along the way you'll notice
a few outward spikes and negative spikes
on this plot we considered deleting
these data points as they're inaccurate
so it's not an accurate representation
of reality so they shouldn't really be
shown but we decided to leave them to
illustrate an important point which is
that the drivers will still
occasionally misreport the frequency so
the alleged spike to twenty to fifty
megahertz and the dip to 700 megahertz
both of these are fake performance
during this benchmark this fixed
workload did not reflect those changes
AMD spent a lot of time talking out how
its new cooler is quiet this time and so
we'll look at that before we get into
the gaming results here's an overtime
thermal chart in our torture workload
like with Radeon seven have a has to GPU
temperatures to know about there's the
GPU temperature as normally presented
it's an edge temperature from the edge
of the die that offers a lower number
and then there's the GPU junction
temperature which is the single hottest
temperature facing clock boosts off of
Junction temperature allows for higher
maximum clocks as the card doesn't have
to run conservatively against an edge
temperature t.j.maxx is 110 degrees
before it starts throttling with the non
overclocked at lower power policy with
the cooler left fully stock and with no
overclock supplied we're climbing up to
95 degrees Celsius toward the end of the
test and still slowly climbing and this
is with the drivers freshly installed so
no weird driver bugs with thermal policy
issues here at all actually this was
with the newer drivers to the memory
temperature measured at about 84 degrees
toward the end of the test which is
approaching the 95 degree temperature
range of GTR six where we stopped being
comfortable and video to be fair also
has issues with memory thermals shown in
our super reviews either card in a
standard case with a case ambience of
about 30 degrees which is easily doable
on a 20 degree room will be running
hotter than we're comfortable with for
memory temperature on the other hand be
REM thermals look pretty good the
hotspot V RMS plot in the range of 65 to
74 degrees Celsius which is completely
acceptable and well under the
recommended range for MOSFETs for the
record Auto fan speeds sat at around
2100 rpm during this test which would
put you in the range of about 52 DBA at
a 20 inch measurement that's very loud
and doesn't at all match a Andy's
marketing of it being quiet it's not
it's the opposite of that so we'll have
noise levels after the gaming later the
next test will fix the fan speed to 40
DBA in our measurements normalizing the
fan rpm to look at how the thermals
respond this is a cooler efficiency test
so we're looking at the efficiency
between a 2070 super cool in a moment
and the 5700 xt cooler both at 40
BA the goal is to see if a user could
lock this cooler down to a reasonable
noise level like 40 DBA
this is actually one of the worst stock
coolers we've ever worked with following
our standardized testing to normalize
for for DBA the GPU climbs to 110
degrees Junction temperature or about a
hundred degrees for edge temperature
which is still unacceptable and begins
to hit a thermal runaway scenario only
prevented because of frequency
throttling on the core we're dropping
clocks here this isn't an open-air bench
with an ambient temperature of just 20
to 22 degrees Celsius so it's only going
to get worse in basically any case
that's out you can see our case reviews
for more of that memory temperatures at
40 DBA are hitting about 97 degrees
Celsius which is uncomfortably warm for
longevity especially once you do put it
in a case and the MOSFETs end up in the
90s well add the 2070 super GP thermals
now a competing card with a higher power
consumption of the 2060 super and so it
should be hotter if anything this would
put things in a Handy's favor because
the 2060 super in the 2070 super use the
same fans but the 2070 super is a higher
power consumption part even still it
doesn't matter the 2070 super founders
edition card plots at 67 degrees Celsius
under full load for its GP temperature
and that's at 40 DBA despite how much we
complain about the screws and the super
glue of the FE cards will give Nvidia
full credit for making something that
doesn't blow quick note on overclocking
before we get into the charts you'll see
a plus 50% power target offset and some
of the benchmarks for games especially
and note that overclocking is presently
mostly broken
it was very broken on the first press
driver and that's because the fan speed
was not set incorrectly so we manually
overrode that and set the a better fan
speed like 75% and then with the updated
press driver we still had issues with
overclocking so we ended up it was
basically impossible to get it stable
anywhere and we ended up just setting it
to plus 50% power target we got 25 to 50
megahertz out of the memory and we
couldn't get anything manually out of
the core because the software doesn't
it's just something's not working so
anyway we set the power target and then
we let the card boost and it did gain
about 100 megahertz by reporting if we
can trust that so it's
still kind of overclocked itself but we
need to revisit overclocking separately
once the drivers are fixed so just
wanted to note that so that when you see
the OC results in the chart hopefully
those will improve once it's functional
so I freely it for is our first test as
always we like to use this one for
reliability consistency and well
optimized DirectX 12 implementation
slightly it was actually originally one
of AMD's best case scenarios in our
testing equina end video was still on
Pascal and just beginning to play around
with asynchronous compute
implementations in retail products
unfortunately for the 5700 XT today's
landscape is different the 5700 XT
manages 71 FPS average in our Sniper
Elite benchmark which places it as 4.2
percent ahead of the RT X 2060 super
before an overclocked is applied with a
trivial overclock on the 2060 super and
ours was one of the worst overclockers
you could ask for it manages to tie the
5700 XT low end frame times are the same
here now it's becoming clear why Andy
dropped the price this wasn't some 5 d
chess mental gymnastics this was a
requirement and something that we
confirmed speaking with people inside of
the companies that work with Andy and
also Andy the RT X 2070 that AMD
originally marketed the 5700 XT against
is also tied with the XT ranking again
at 71 FPS average on some retailers like
Amazon with an MSI RT x 2070 the
non-super 27 TS are now available for
about 450 to 460 dollars as
manufacturers try to clear out the stock
the RTR 27 is super now $100 over the
5,700 XD after the price reduction
manages a lead of eleven point seven
percent over the 5700 XT one both are
stock overclocking the 5700 XT resulted
in an increase of about 6% over the 5700
XT stock the clock averaged in the range
of 1970 to 2017 megahertz as reported by
the Psalter with this plus 50% power
target but it's hard to tell since the
frequency is misreporting through
software anyway
it's sometimes show for instance 65,000
megahertz which would be and probably
the best overclock ever in history if it
were accurate Radeon 7 actually before
reasonably in this game which isn't true
in every scenario the extra see you
count seems to help in a significant way
for this title strange Brigade is up
next this one is built by the same
company as Sniper Elite 4 and it's built
equally well but instead gives us
coverage of the Vulcan API
additionally we can use strange Brigade
to demonstrate the scaling Delta from
Vulcan to DirectX 12 with each GPU well
get some 1080p tests shortly but
starting with 1440p and the Vulkan API
and these are our X 60 700 XT runs at
122 FPS average with lows of 105 fps or
1% 104 for 0.1% the 5700 XT ends up
about 1.3 percent ahead of the non-ace
qrt x 2070 and roughly within our error
margins this marks the two as
functionally identical and a skew 2070
would plays higher here approaching the
2070 overclock that we have on this
chart but it would still be between the
20s OD black and 2070 black OC which our
performs the 5700 XT the RT X 2060
supercard is led by the 5700 XT by about
4% overclocking suber puts it beyond the
5700 xt stock and overclocked results
the latter of which does bugged as a
result of poor launch drivers something
for which aim the Radeon has become a
repeat offender in terms of price the
2060 super compares most directly to the
5700 XT and that's before getting into
things like noise thermals and power
something we'll do later for gaming
there within a few percentage points of
each other in this benchmark the RT X
2070 super is on another level here
placing 12% ahead of in performance when
stock but after those price changes it
is also now another price category as
well
sometimes we see the performance stack
change as resolution increases
potentially illustrating Rob's or memory
limitations things like that bandwidth
limitations at 4k the RX 5700 XT sits at
Sony one FPS average ranking as equal to
NRT X 2060 supercard when it's
overclocked 1% lows are within error
margins here performance over a non a
skew 2070 the lower bin one the one that
launched at MSRP in October that's why
it's on the chart because it was
actually MSRP it shows a performance
lead about 5.6 percent for the xt
rel it's
to 1440p this is better performance when
scaled against the old 20 70 the new
r-tx 20 70 now $100 more expensive again
so 250 ends up at 77 FPS average and
leads the 5700 XT by 8% one stock
overclocking increases that lead to 18%
overall at 4k the 5700 XT recovers much
of its losses from the 1440p results
this next chart looks at performance
scaling between the two API is available
in strange brigade the chart is ordered
by best average FPS in Vulcan and 100%
number here bar would mean equivalence
with Vulcan
whereas numbers below 100% indicates
that performance is worse on DX 12 and
numbers over 100% indicate better
performance on DX 12 and this is all DX
12 relative performance scaling versus
Vulcan baseline the RX 5700 xt performs
about 1.5 percent better with DirectX 12
nearing error margins and the
overclocked puts a 3% over Vulcan
performance and thee is doing better in
DX 12 in Vulcan for this title although
its marginal in this instance f1 2018 is
next and give us a look at an older more
standard DirectX 11 implementation for
this one the rx 5700 XT runs at 150 FPS
average with lows at 102 and 73 this
positions the stock 5700 XT is about
nine point nine percent ahead of the RT
X 2017 on a GPU for everyone who felt
buyer's remorse over there RT x 20
series purchases when super came out
this week you're not alone now the AMD
Radeon 7 buyers can feel the same
remorse because an AMD card that's
nearly three hundred dollars cheaper
achieves the same performance in this
game as the Radeon seven did when it
launched five months ago if you're using
Radeon seven and professional
applications and you can get use of that
memory you dodged some of this bullet by
way of the extra VM having an actual use
case for you but it just doesn't really
matter in these gaming workloads more
notably as has always been the case with
this game AMD maintains significantly
improved training times over Nvidia
cards this is something we've observed
with every other reason to Andy card in
this specific title although that flips
a bit as you look at other games this
frame time plot will illustrate the
peculiar behavior of the cards in this
benchmark 5700 XT holds steady at about
eight to nine millisecond frame to frame
intervals with almost no excursions from
that average we typically start seeing
the excursions once they exceed eight to
twelve millisecond spikes the 2070
bounces between five milliseconds at the
low end and 16 milliseconds at the high
end marking the 5,700 XC has a better
experience in this title 1440p 4f 1 2018
positions that are x2 the 700 xt at 115
FPS average which is roughly tied with
an overclocked 2070 black and superior
to the stock RT x 2070 black the RT x
2060 super with an overclock reaches 110
FPS average placing the 5700 xt stock
GPU 4% ahead of the 2016 Subaru that
overclocked the rx 5700 XT with 50% more
power roughly matches the stock Radeon 7
with the 2070 super leading the stock rx
57 or XT by 7% at 4k the 700 xt muscles
ahead of the overclocked 2070 black in
f1 2018 and lands between the 2016
Subaru C and 2070 super stock
performance overclocking doesn't do
anything meaningful for us here but we
think that's primarily because the
drivers are broken although we don't
expect much Headroom here anyway because
Andy has severely locked down
overclocking to the point of it being a
tremendous disappointment hip an - is up
next
first with DirectX 12 at 1080p hitman 2
positions the RX 5700 xt about equal
with an overclocked RDX 2060 super or
about 3.8 percent ahead of the RT x 2060
super 1 stock the 2070 super leads the
5700 XT by 9% in this title versus the
RT X 2070 the 5700 XT leads by about 4
to 5 percent and average FPS and that's
2070 black edition to be clear with
DirectX 12 and hitman all devices have a
hard time with 0.1% low values but we'll
note fairly that Nvidia is RT X 26 super
is substantially improved over the 57 XD
this is the inverse scenario as with f1
2018 so Nvidia is pulling ahead in this
one specifically for player experience
at 1440p that rx 5700 X he ends up with
in error margins of the AMD Radeon 7gp
who and tied an average FPS with the
overclocked r-tx 2060 super the 2060
Super Stock GPU ends up at 76 FPS
average to the 5700 XT is 81 FPS average
but the 2060 super maintains better 0.1%
lowest
mark and that's a better experience
again the inverse of F 1 2018 results
DirectX 11 gives everyone in
improvements in 0.1% low performance
seen here at 1440p the RX with you 700
XT is now functionally tied with the RT
X 2020 black and RT X 2060 founders
Edition 1 overclocked that's not super
mind you that's the 2060 the RTR 2060
super it leads marginally roughly with
an error and a 2060 super with an
overclocked leads the pack of $400 cards
at 4k there's these 700 XT runs a 43 FPS
average about tied of the 2070 black
although the 2070 has significantly
better lows the RT or 2060 super is also
function tied with both of these cards
and this is back on the x12 mind you
shadow of the Tomb Raider at 1080p is up
next for this one the 5700 XT place is
just below the r-tx 20 somebody super so
it does well in this benchmark
performance has it at 124 FPS average
compared to the 126 FPS average of the
2070 super this also positions the rx100
xt ahead of the Radeon 7 card one stock
and about 15% ahead of the RT x 27 t
Black Card 1440p places the 5700 XT
marginally ahead of the overclocked to
27 t black card and about 15% the head
of the RT X 2060 super the RT x 27 t
super maintains a lead of 5.3% Radeon 7
can unfortunately once again join the RT
X 2060 and 2070 owners in the morning in
the corner at 4k and these are rx 5700
XT and 2070 super keep the same distance
as before with the 2070 super about 6%
ahead
technically the super is gaining
distance as resolution increases but
it's not too much each time it is it is
notable though the 5700 XT outperforms
the stock RT X 20 so d black and the
2060 super by about 16% this is the last
game before we get into power thermals
and noise which are very important for
this blower card far cry 5 at 1080 P
positions the RT X 2060 super 2070 black
and if it's 200 XT all in good company
Susy's have 100 XT it leads the 2060
super by about 4.7 percent although the
2060 super maintains better frame pacing
than the 5700 XT this is an instance
where it's measurable but probably not
perceptible overclocking the 2060 super
ties it with the presently
- rx 57 100 XT overclocked both of which
reach upwards toward a stock RT acts
20:7 a super 3dmark time spy is last
before we get into those power numbers
this is useful for looking at
performance more individually of the GPU
and memory GT Wan is a GPU intensive
workload whereas that's core clock
whereas gt2 is more memory intensive
this chart is sorted by total combined
score not shown but measured in the
thousands as gt1 and gt2 each have a
weight contributing to that 4 times pi
we measured the 5700 xt at 60 FPS
average GT one across multiple test
passes which positions Navi ahead of the
2062 / by 7% in GT 1 but allow is that
the supercar deleted in GT 2 by 2.2
percent super has more efficient memory
in GT 2 which could come down to things
like Delta color compression but we need
to dig into it more after release in a
separate content piece potentially
50-100 XT ends up about where Radeon 7
is in this test but the 2060 super with
a light overclock blasts it ahead in
total score GT 1 ends up at 60 point 8 f
PS not far from the 5700 XT but GT 2
polls far ahead note that every single
tenth of a point in FPS is important in
3dmark scoring 2070 super leads in total
score at 10000 181 points whereas the
5700 XT is eight thousand eight hundred
ten points netting a 16% lead although
we didn't show those numbers because
they're too big and they blow out the
scale but that's all you need to know
for those power consumption is next our
new power consumption testing for GPUs
measures at the 12 volt rails although
he took some 3.3 volt rail measurements
for the new super and Navi cart this
testing is done with a custom-built
interposer to measure PCIe slot draw as
well as the 12 volt PCIe cable power
consumption down the power supply cables
these charts will list the TDP for AMD
and NVIDIA parts but note that Nvidia
defines its power consumption based upon
the GPU and AMD defines its power
consumption based upon the total board
power which is everything on the board
we're looking at synthetics for the
first test the power virus per mark puts
AMD's RX 5700 xt at 217 watts with just
the 12 volt cables and PCIe slot
measured we separately measured the 3.3
volt slot power consumption
plotted here as polling 0.9 amps or
about 3 watts extra we're right at about
the TDP figure plus or minus some
measurement error the RT X 2060 super
polls 164 watts or about 175 max if you
include measurement error and maybe a
couple of watts down 3.3 volt and
overclocked in the 2060 super puts it at
209 watts power consumption is finally
getting closer
it took AMD an entire node shrink to
almost match and videos power
consumption at the same performance
level but they got there eventually the
our TX 2070 pulls at 214 watts for
reference and amusingly applying a 50%
power offset to the RX 5700 XT actually
does what it suggests and increases
power consumption by about 54% from the
217 watt figure previously with the over
power setting applied we measure about
335 watts to average in the range of
1990 to 2017 megahertz assuming watt man
and GPZ aren't totally inaccurate it's
not worth the three to four FPS that we
gained on average to generate that much
more heat since the power into the PC
does effectively just make it a space
heater also considering what a twenty
ATT I can get done for the same amount
of power this highlights that Navi has
difficulty scaling performance with
higher power consumption than the spec
it's just it unfortunately it's not
linear it doesn't work that way
f1 2018 at 1440p places the 5700 XT at
206 Watts from 12 volt power which is
about 30 watts more than the r-tx 2070
supercard as a reminder in this game the
2070 super outperformed the rx with you
700 XT by 7.2 percent meaning that it
operated at 15% less power while doing
so the rx 2060 super runs at 164 point 4
watts in this workload for reference
with an overclock pushing it to 200
watts for 4k resolution the 5700 XT runs
at 214 watts for 4k with the overpowered
5700 XT at 281 watts for 4k
back to noise levels despite and these
marketing the rx 5700 XT runs loud and
relatively hot 40 DBA seems to happen at
about 1650 rpm or so about 20 inches
away and noise levels are made worse by
some sort of resonant frequency issue
within the cooler
maybe Turbie
err making noise inside of the shroud or
maybe a bearing for the fat the noise
levels for the card end up looking like
this the curve plots above everything
else here for the 5700 XT with all the
others being dual fan coolers are better
like the Radeon seven triple fan axial
cooler the 5700 XT is a hard regression
in design MD needs to concede that it
can't make what any reasonable person
considers to be a quote actually pretty
good and quiet blower cooler it's not
happening here and this is certainly not
is the same conclusion as we come to
with all the other blower reference
coolers which is don't buy it just buy a
partner model if you're going to buy the
card the partner models will be far far
better for thermal and acoustic
performance finally reaching the end of
all of this data there are a couple of
things first of all gaming performance
is its up and down it's like a tennis
match and some of the games we've tested
like some of the older dx11 titles for
example surprisingly Navi has done
pretty well so it's it's actually
genuinely fairly competitive in some of
those titles after the price reduction
is taken into account so this is not 5d
chess this is they had to drop the price
and that's fine it doesn't matter why
they drop the price so all that matters
is that it's lowered how and and it was
before anyone ordered which oh that's a
dummy sample it's it's actually not
functional so don't worry about it
that'll be in our teardown later it
should've mentioned that earlier where
this card doesn't do well is in thermals
and we've given this part of the review
to Nvidia in the past as well when they
used to do blower cards and we still
kind of ribbed them over there a lot for
their since their new founders edition
designs but the review we always gave to
blow our cards was that they're not
worth it and there are instances where
you could justify it for example if you
wanted to buy the reference board and
stick a water cooler on it sure the V
rhyme is good enough you should skip the
blower design it's just not good so the
card itself if you want to buy it that's
fine it's okay it's competitive int to
good and some of the scenarios like GTA
5 for example I don't know if we put
that one in here but GTA 5 it did pretty
well
f1 2018 the frame
times are fantastic and f1 2018 for any
time to take a hit in the x12 with
hitman 2 everything kind of does but
Andy a bit more than others so it's a
bit give-and-take but the card itself
without the cooler is is a reasonable
purchase get it with a different cooler
though that's the recommendation we make
so where do we go from here well drivers
those are an issue the we ran into a lot
of the driver bugs we've seen in the
past and we'll put some on the screen
here where it does the multicolored
thing when you first install this isn't
even just press drivers a lot of these
photos are from the public drivers the
new public drivers on RX 590 in the
Radeon seven so it's not even unreleased
stuff that this is happening on it's
been happening for years this is on
multiple different systems we've had it
happen over multiple different years now
and just in the last week three
different systems three different
monitors two different motherboards same
thing happens we different operating
systems and/or installs anyway 19:03
problem so drivers are a problem it's
not a great user experience you can work
around that one by rebooting but it'll
happen every now and then if you leave
the system item I don't let the screen
go to sleep other issues with the
drivers include overclocking being
broken so this is the biggest point to
bring it back to is that currently with
the drivers we have overclocking does
not function in a way that it seems like
it makes sense even with the updated
version with the updated thermal policy
which really just means the fan is
faster it's still not functioning well
you should basically set the power
target to plus 50% and then stop
touching the dials because the frequency
at that point will auto jump to
something that's probably kind of stable
and any tuning beyond that it was just
we had all kinds of issues of the
drivers so we'll revisit that once they
fix them up and this is something any of
these aware of it is something that AMD
is working on very brief recap then the
Navi card in comparison to the rise and
launch is a letdown the r5 3600 was much
more compelling and for example as is
the 3900 X the Navi card has significant
issues with thermal with noise it is it
required a node process shrink to become
competitive with NVIDIA and
power consumption is still a higher on
average but it's not significant anymore
so that is will give credit there it's
not as bad it's actually powers high
earth and NVIDIA but it's not high so
it's not to a point where it's actually
going to matter for basically anyone so
performance wise the GPU is defensible
as a purchase it's fine don't buy this
one buy one buy a partner with a good
cooler on it and you'll be much happier
I think that pretty much sums up our
review it's fine with a different cooler
and that'll cap it for us here so thank
you for watching subscribe for more as
always it's been a busy day one of them
and you can go to store that Cameron's
Nexus dotnet to support a strikethrough
by picking up a tool kit or a mod mad
and patreon.com slash gamers Nexus and
definitely check back on the channel for
the teardown of this card because we do
some cool stuff with it so I'll see you
all next time